this is a dumb question
what are you uh no tell me a dumb
question i want to hear it
okay uh i mean okay this is the question
about beauty it's way too gentle it's
very impossible
it's like asking what's your favorite
band uh what's your favorite music band
oh i thought you meant wavelength band i
was like i definitely have favorite boy
with my friends absolutely
well it's hard to narrow down huh okay
uh
what uh what to use the most beautiful
idea
in science that's not a dumb question
do you want to try the question again
proudly okay
i i have a really good question to ask
you
okay don't oversell it an okay question
to ask you know
eva yeah what uh
what to you is the most beautiful idea
in uh
in science something you just find
inspiring or just
maybe the reason you got into science or
the reason you think science is cool
my favorite thing about science is kind
of the connection between the scales
so when i was little and i wanted to
know about space i
really felt that it would make me feel
powerful
to be able to predict the heavens
something so much larger than myself
that felt really powerful it was almost
a selfish desire
and that's what i wanted there was some
control to being able to know exactly
what the sky would do and then as i got
older and i got more into astronomy and
i didn't just want to know how the stars
moved i wanted to know how the planets
around them moved and
and then as i got deeper into that field
i really didn't care that much about the
planets i want to know about the
atmospheres around the planets and then
the molecules within those atmospheres
and what that might mean
so i ended up shrinking my scale until
it was
literally the quantum scale and now all
my work
the majority of my work is on this
insane quantum
scale and yet i'm using these
literal tiny tiny tools
to try and answer the greatest questions
that we've ever been able to ask and
this
crossing of scales from the quantum to
the astronomical
that's so cool isn't it yeah it spends
the entirety
the tiny and the huge that's that's the
cool thing about
i guess being a quantum master chemist
is you're using the tools of the tiny to
uh look at the heavenly bodies the
the giant stuff and the potential life
out there that this is the
thing that connects us that you can't
escape the rules of the quantum world
and how universal they themselves are
despite
being probabilistic and that
makes me feel really pleased to be in
science but in a really humbling way
it's no longer this thirst for power
and i i feel less special the more work
i do
less exceptional the more work i do i
feel like humans and the earth
and our place in the universe is less
and less exceptional
and yet i feel so much less lonely
and so it's been a really good trade-off
that i've lost power but i've
gained company wow that's a beautiful
answer i don't think there's a better
way to actually end it you're right
i asked a mediocre question and you came
through uh
you made the question good by a
brilliant answer
um you're the michael jordan and i'm the
who's the uh dennis rod i'll be the
dennis rodman hey this is
don't know enough about basketball i
mean literally you've reached the peak
of my basketball knowledge
because i know those people are
basketball but that's it
pros i believe but only because i watch
space jam i think
you